les matins de france culture 7h 9h
guillaume erner bonjour jean marc
jancovici
vous êtes un spécialiste de l'énergie
président du film tant que chief project
projet professeur à mines paristech et
je vous invitais parce que l'énergie est
dans l'actualité deux exemples donald
trump s'est félicité lundi de
l'officialisation du retrait de son pays
de l'accord de paris et il en a profité
pour vanter les mérites du magnifique
charbon propre américain et une semaine
plus tôt la filière nucléaire française
était pointée du doigt avec un rapport
un rapport à charge sur les difficultés
du chantier de le p r de flamanville
alors qu emmanuel macron a promis que la
part du nucléaire serait ramené à 50% de
la production d'électricité à l'horizon
2035 et je sais que vous n'avez pas très
envie de parler du nucléaire vous avez
dit que vous ne vouliez pas en parler
plus de 20% du temps de l'émission
expliquez moi pourquoi j'ai pas dit
j'avais pas envie de parler nucléaire
j'ai dit je n'avais pas envie de parler
que de ça il ya une blague qu'on fait
souvent dans les milieux qui s'occupe un
peu d'énergie qui est de dire le
nucléaire c'est 5 % de nos problèmes et
c'est 95% du temps de débat
voilà donc c'est bon on a pas que ça
comme problème en ce qui concerne
l'énergie
d'abord il faut rappeler une chose en ce
qui concerne l'énergie c'est que
l'énergie c'est pas un secteur à part
c'est ce qui permet au monde moderne
d'exister s'il n'y a pas d'énergie vous
n'êtes pas présentateur de la matinale
vont ramasser des patates
ce qui est une vie un tout petit peu
différente les gens qui nous écoutent
n'ont pas de logement protéger du froid
et du chaud ils n'ont pas de voiture ils
n'ont pas de viande à tous les repas
étant parfois donc tout ce que nous
avons aujourd'hui dans le monde moderne
pouvoir d'achat et des retraites
c'est l'énergie qu'il a permis donc
discuter de l'énergie en fait c'est
discuter de tout ce qui nous entoure
aujourd'hui l'essentiel de ce qui permet
ça dans le monde c'est pas du tout
nucléaire c'est des combustibles
fossiles c'est à dire le pétrole le
charbon et le gaz
il se trouve qu'en france 60
allez on va dire les deux tiers de nos
émissions de co2 c'est à dire ce qui
provoque le changement climatique ça
vient du pétrole un car ça vient du gaz
et 5% ça vient du charbon et 2 0% vire
du nucléaire donc le bien que le
nucléaire les inconvénients il y en a
mais ne parler que du nucléaire est
quelque chose qui finit par devenir un
peu contre-productif
par ailleurs en ce qui concerne la
décision d' emmanuel macron
personnellement je la comprends toujours
pas c'est à dire je comprenais pas la
décision de hollande a que baisser
nucléaire à 50% soit une bonne idée
je pense que c'est dilapider des moyens
dans un truc qui n'a aucun intérêt
par contre et je tête de la politique et
la politique devrait faire des choses
qui n'ont aucun intérêt non mais en tout
cas la politique veut faire ce que les
gens voudraient qu'ils fassent en un an
un an et hollande il a fait ça parce
qu'ils voulaient les 3 % des lecteurs
vers qui lui ont permis d'être élu chef
c'est ce qu'on appelle la politique
non parce que ce que 3% des électeurs
veulent c'est pas ce que veut la
collectivité donc quand vous dites c'est
ce que les gens volent aux assad et pour
lesquelles bon alors il a quitté alger
un rapport qui est le rapport de jean
martin folz qu'elle vient construction
de le p r de flamanville qui explique
alors je vais revenir brièvement large
que ça son rapport en tout cas il évoque
et 10 milliards de dépassement de budget
un retard jeudi un retard de dix ans en
fait je devrais dire plus puisque on ne
sait pas quand est-ce que cette paire il
a fonctionné
ce rapport qui montre quand même que le
nucléaire du futur il a deux trois
petits soucis dans le nucléaire français
est de 36 au sipal nucléaire du futur
les chinois ont actuellement pleins de
réacteur qui fonctionne qui ont été
construits en cinq ans les opère même
les ep air qui sont des réacteurs ne
sais pas dans quelles conditions qui les
chars on ne sait pas dans quelles
conditions vous ne savez pas l'auteur
absolument l'autorité de suler de sûreté
nucléaire française ne sais pas dans
quelles conditions je ne sais pas j'ai
pas si vous avez lu tous les rapports
dans tous les rapports mais j'ai fait un
super fait là ce sujet est l'un des
experts les dalles et voilà on ne s'est
pas alarmé experts ne s'est pas d'accord
mais il faut toujours savoir sais pas
dans quelle mesure l autorité de sûreté
nucléaire et joueront preumont canaille
c'est à dire que quand vous dites on ne
sait pas ça ne dit pas qui ne sait pas
alors attendez on va expliquer justo aux
auditeurs un instant de quoi il s'agit
le père de flamanville
il souffre d'un certain nombre de
problèmes il a notamment un problème de
couvercles son couvercle je vais le dire
avec mes mots et vous le dirai avec les
mots des experts ce couvercle il n'est
pas sûr et on a considéré qu'il ne
pouvait pas fonctionner avec ce
couvercle là on sait pas en chine
le pea fonctionne et
ne sais pas si on le tient inadéquat
mais disons que l'autorité de sûreté
nucléaire française ne sais pas dans
quelle mesure ce couvercle il est
identique à ce qu'il aurait dû être en
france et donc inadapté à des prénoms va
on va repartir on va repartir du début
vous avez eu aujourd'hui trois accidents
sérieux de centrales nucléaires dans le
monde
2 on fait zéro mort 0 free mile island
et fukushima on fait zéro mort à cause
de la partie nucléaire
le seul accident qui est fait des morts
c'est tchernobyl
tchernobyl est intervenu sur un réacteur
qui est un modèle qui n'existe ni en
france ni en chine donc et tous les
accidents ne se valent pas c'est pas on
peut pas avoir n'importe quel type
d'accident sur n'importe quelle centrale
donc savoir
en fait la question de la sûreté en ce
qui concerne le nucléaire est un est une
question qui est le risque zéro n'existe
nulle part dans le monde et la question
est de savoir jusqu'où est ce qu on
rajoute des milliards pour se protéger
contre un surplus de risques alors que
ces mêmes milliards employés ailleurs
aurait permis d'éviter plus de malheur
aux hommes
c'est ça la question c'est de celle de
l'arbitrage là le risque zéro encore une
fois n'existe nulle part
ce que dit le rapport de jean martin
folz
c'est que la filière française a perdu
de la compétence ça c'est tout à fait il
ne dit pas on a un problème de sûreté le
reste il peut d'autant moins le dire que
c'est pas son domaine
on a une autorité de sûreté en france
qui est là pour ça et c'est pas le job
de le foll cela soit pour l'instant le
père ne fonctionne pas donc on n'a pas
de problème on a joué les pères
fonctionne très bien il y en a deux en
chine touche m soldes le p r de
flamanville alors donc faut être précis
donc le père de flamanville n'est pas
encore en fonction les opéras chinois
fonctionnent très bien ils
fonctionneront en service commercial à
pleine puissance
aujourd'hui le ils ont été construits
avec là aussi un dépassement calendaire
et un dépassement de budget mais pour
des têtes de série c'est quelque chose
qu'il faut luxe avec la tour eiffel a
été construite pour trois fois son
budget initial
eurotunnel a été construit pour cinq
fois son budget initial et le gisement
de kashagan au nord de la mer caspienne
qui est un gisement pétrolier a été
construit pour diffamer l'exploitation
été comprise construite pour dix fois
son budget initial
donc le fait qu'il ya des dépassements
de budget c'est pas quelque chose qui en
soi est porteur d'un danger la tour
eiffel c'est pas dangereux ne pense pas
que tous les touristes qui montent
dessus tous les jours
meurt parce que ça a été construit pour
trois fois le budget initial donc il ya
deux choses qu'il faut bien séparer il
ya les questions de danger et il ya les
questions de surcoûts et on parle pas de
la même chose donc falls a dit ya un
surcoût et c'est pas normal qu'ils aient
un surcoût dans des proportions de cette
aile et je suis évidemment d'accord avec
lui alors la question c'est pourquoi est
ce qu'il ya eu un surcoût et folk en
gros ils ont ils distribuent les mauvais
points à tout le monde donc il distribue
les mauvais points aux gens qui ont
construit la centrale parce qu'ils
disent que les gens se sont avancés de
façon un peu imprudente à dire on sait
faire alors qu'eux ils savaient pas
enfin il est il fallait qu'ils
retrouvent la main donc en gros le
budget initial était totalement
fantaisistes le délai initial prévu
était aussi totalement fantaisistes
maintenant la bonne question c'est
pourquoi est-ce que la filière française
a perdu de la compétence et alors elle a
perdu de la compétence 1 parce que ça
fait 20 ans qu'elle n'a rien construit
mais deux parce que ça fait quinze ans
qu'elle est otage de manoeuvre
politicienne à courte vue et que quand
pendant 15 ans le pouvoir politique vous
dis en sous-main sait très bien ce que
vous faites pendant qu'il dit en public
ce que vous faites c'est nul à un moment
ça pose quand même quelques petits
problèmes dans la gestion de la filière
donc et sa folle je le dis en creux
aussi il ya aujourd'hui vis-à-vis du
nucléaire
malgré tout des inquiétudes alors vous
dites fukushima n'a tué personne
est-ce que sur le moyen terme on peut en
être aussi certains est que les cancers
sur le lieu à des lieux qui aujourd'hui
sont ce que vous avez calais le salarié
le plus irradiés de france
non je ne sais pas si vous le connaissez
vous connaissez très bien son nom aux
salariés de plusieurs radiers de france
il s'appelle thomas pesquet faites pas
cette tête il ne s'appelle pas parce
qu'elle fait confiance parce que quand
vous allez dans l'espace vous prenez du
rayonnement cosmique qui est une forme
de rayonnement ionisant
on a des particules qui sont projetés à
grande vitesse et thomas pesquet prend
pendant les six mois que dure son séjour
dans la station spatiale internationale
à peu près neuf fois la dose maximale
admissible pour un travailleur du
nucléaire en france deux fois et
toujours vivant
donc après la deuxième catégorie de la
première catégorie de salariés
globalement la plus irradiés dans ce
pays alors il doit y avoir des
professions médicales qui sont pas mal
et radier les chirurgiens qui opère sous
joug 12 appareils d'imagerie etc mais
vous en avez une clé plusieurs radiers
que les travailleurs du nucléaire c'est
les travailleurs du transport aérien
le personnel navigant aérien toujours
pour les mêmes raisons parce qu'il est
plus exposés aux rayonnements cosmiques
quand il est à 10000 mètres d'altitude
est en moyenne plus irradiés que les
salariés d'edf et de la filière
nucléaire
donc vous n'avez pas nécessairement tout
le monde qui meurent à partir du moment
où vous êtes exposés aux rayonnements
ionisants ça veut dire que selon vous
fukushima ne s'est pas selon moi il se
trouve qu'il ya un vous avez peut-être
entendu parler du giec
ça vous dit quelque chose le giec est
une instance onusienne qui a le mandat
de compiler de synthétiser ce qui est
disponible dans la littérature
scientifique sur l'influencé de l'homme
sur le climat
il se trouve que les nations unies ont
créé en 1955 donc trente trois ans avant
la création du giec
une autre agence onusienne qui s'appelle
avec un accent délibérément france l'une
skyarts c'est-à-dire united nations
scientific committee andy effects of
atomic radiations qui donc dont les
rapports sont superbement ignorés par
les médias français donc ça c'est une
bonne question la bonne question c'est
pourquoi ce que les médias français
ignorent superbement celle-ci vous faut
c'est parce qu'elle a c'est pas moi qui
ai la riposte est question moi je
travaille pas dans les médias français
donc c'est rapport compile la
littérature scientifique qui est
disponible sur l' influence des
rayonnements ionisants sur les hommes
alors des rayonnements ionisants vous en
prenez vous en prenez à cause du
rayonnement cosmique vous en prenez à
cause du rayonnement terrestre
tellurique vous en prenez à cause des
radios et d'imagerie médicale et la
question c'est pas est ce que vous allez
mourir si vous en prenez pas ce que ça
la réponse est non la question c'est
jusqu'à quelle dose est ce que vous
pouvez aller avant que ça commence à
devenir enquiquinant ça fait très très
longtemps qu'il ya des études sur la
question c'est très bien depuis
longtemps que marie curie est morte à
cause de ça et en 1928 il ya déjà un
premier première commission de
protection contre les rayonnements
ionisants qui avaient été mises en place
donc c'est il ya un siècle de
littérature scientifique là dessus
et l'usc et arts a rendu des rapports de
400 pages en anglais que personne ne lit
à la fois sur tchernobyl et fukushima
est la conclusion du rapport soutient
mobile on est d'accord pour dire qu'il
ya eu des morts l'azur des rayons a fait
des morts bien sûr je peux je peux je
peux vous dire qu'il ya dans les
rapports en question que vous pouvez
aller vérifier en ce qui concerne
fukushima le rapport dit il n'y aura pas
de mort à cause du surplus de
rayonnements ionisants viendra pas voilà
c est écrit noir sur blanc je vous crois
en revanche pas moi qui fais pas tourner
les gens c'est les gens qui mais vous
savez la difficulté des journalistes
nous on interroge des experts vous êtes
un expert donc je voulais fait confiance
et vous êtes là pour développer votre
pensée en revanche je me souviens en
tant que journaliste de la catastrophe
de fukushima à l'époque on nous avait
dit en france c'est pas possible c'est
pas possible parce qu'effectivement le
geste de tunnels sais pas qui vous a dit
ça
le tsunami en france n'est pas possible
ça c'est soit là ça on est on est
d'accord là ils font une fonte du coeur
en france est possible
et si ça devait arriver ça fera
probablement la même chose qu'à
fukushima c'est à dire que le coeur
fondu restera à l'intérieur de la
centrale et y aura pas de conséquences à
l'extérieur exactement comme ça s'est
passé à three mile island mais au prix
miles island
il s'en est fallu d'un cheveu pour que
je lui ai d'ailleurs il s'en est fallu
d'un le coeur a fondu est resté dedans
voilà il s'en est fallu d'un cheveu pour
qu'ils font il a fondu mais l'une des
questions par exemple pour le p r c'est
que le p r on développe nous a été
vendue comme étant un système
extrêmement sûre avec donc alors le
vainqueur sans même aller jusqu'à le p r
les réacteurs actuels sont prévues en
france pour que si ça fond ça reste
dedans
est ce que aujourd'hui on peut dire sans
risque que le choeur ou ne transperce
durable risque alors le risque n'existe
pas de risque zéro n'existe pas par
contre ce qui est dommage aujourd'hui
c'est que dans le public qui est une
compréhension du risque nucléaire qui
soit totalement erronée alors je vais
vous donner un premier exemple de fake
médiatique parce que pour moi c'en est
une
80% des français pensent que le
nucléaire contribue au changement
climatique
alors il peut avoir tous les défauts de
la terre mais pas celui là après il ya
énormément de joie quand vous faites des
baromètre d'opinion en france les
déchets nucléaires font plus peur à la
population que tenez vous bien les
accidents de la route que les accidents
domestiques les accidents domestiques
ces vingt mille morts par an les déchets
nucléaires c'est zéro
ça fait plus peur que l'obésité chez les
jeunes ça fait quasiment aussi peur que
le tabagisme d'accord donc il ya une
espèce de peur fantasmée dans l'opinion
et c'est la raison pour laquelle en
entrant ici je vous avais dit je ne veux
pas parler que de ça parce que on va
parler le problème du nucléaire n'est
pas un problème de risque ou plus
exactement de danger objectif c'est un
problème de risques perçus donc en fait
le vrai débat sur le nucléaire c'est
pourquoi est ce que les médias sont pas
foutus de fournir une information
factuelle objectif parce qu'il ya les
faits les opinions qui est encore mais
dis donc t'es aussi les experts alors
regardez par exemple qui a le rapport
leur a donné ce matin de venir dans
studio vous je suis pour moquer décidé
je suis passé par là en disant qu'il ya
de la lumière je rentrais vous ayez un
vide et je vous ai invités pour que vous
me donniez votre point de vue dans tous
les autres savent aussi qu'ils avaient
invité regarde et on confrères pareil le
rapport de jean martin folz sur le père
de flamanville il a un mot qui est un
mot a priori incompréhensible pour le
grand public dossier barré est aussi
barré ça veut dire quoi ça veut dire en
fait que dans le père de flamanville il
ya certaines pièces qui ont été déclarés
parfaitement sains propres wind à
l'utilisation du nucléaire ça se fait
entre experts c'est à dire entre des
gens qui s'y connaissent qui prétendent
s'y connaître qui font notre bien à
notre insu et on a mis dans cette
centrale nucléaire dans cette p r des
pièces qui sont des pièces qui
manifestement ne conviennent pas et on
n'est même pas capable de mettre dans un
rapport que ce n'est pas un dossier
barré que c'est tout simplement une
pièce impropre comme si on mettait les
plaquettes de frein alors il ya eu il ya
une autorité qui n'ont justement le
parallèle n'est pas bon il ya une
autorité qui est là pour dire si on peut
mettre ou pas cette pièce dans le
réacteur qui s'appelle l'asn donc l'asn
l'autorité de sûreté nucléaire
regarde les choses en détails et vous
dit on peut on peut pas si vous avez une
plaquette de frein sur votre sur votre
voiture dont la norme et qu'elle doit
faire 3 cm d'épaisseur et il se trouve
qu'elle en fait 2,8
sauf que ça devient dangereux à partir
du moment où on en fait moins de 0,5
bah c'est pas conformes mais c'est pas
dangereux d'accord donc l'asn est là
pour dire est-ce que c'est dangereux ou
pas dangereux indépendamment du fait que
ce soit conforme pas conforme
c'est son job donc si l'asn ne vous dis
pas faut pas mettre la pièce c'est que
la pièce pouvait ne pas être conforme à
la spécification et pour autant la
spécification à de telles marges
tolérance que c'est pas dangereux c'est
pas mon job et c'est pas le vôtre donc
moi je suis incapable de vous dire s'il
fallait ou pas mettre cette pièce il
fallait ou pas mettre cette pièce nos
réacteurs tout ce que je vous dis c'est
l'asn a dit on peut jean marc jancovici
j'ai une dernière question à vous poser
sur le nucléaire bon on a vu qu'il y
avait un certain nombre de risques alors
vous considérez que les médias ne font
pas leur travail en attisant en quelque
sorte la peur des gens en inde il ya un
nouveau risque qui a été observé puisque
les autorités indiennes de sûreté
nucléaire ont reconnu mercredi dernier
qu'un virus informatique avait été
détecté dans une centrale dans l'état du
tamil nadu
ça c'est un nouveau risque est ce que
par exemple ça c'est quelque chose qu'on
avait prévu je n'en ai aucune idée
parce qu'il faut savoir il faut vous
comprenez on a un problème dans le monde
moderne c'est pas propre nucléaire c'est
que le monde est devenu tellement
compliqué que plus personne ne peut par
lui-même comprendre et maîtriser toutes
les techniques qui nous entoure donc
vous en est réduit à chaque fois à
devoir faire confiance à des tiers vous
comme ça que les joueurs à lens vos
communes que je fais j'ai un vieux chez
les ibères si je peux finir je suis
expert certes mais je ne suis pas expert
au point de savoir de quel virus il
s'agit où il pourrait s'agir est-ce
qu'on est dans le fantasme est ce qu on
est dans la réalité
donc elles sont nées dans la légende
urbaine ou quelque chose qui est fondée
voilà donc à ce stade je vous dis moi je
ne sais pas et ça veut dire que lorsque
l'aiea si vous me demandez est ce que
vous êtes très inquiet je vais vous dire
non je ne suis pas très inquiet avec
cette information il peut aussi y avoir
vous savez des virus dans les tours de
contrôle et les avions s'écrasent il
peut y avoir des vivres des avions qui
s'écrasent également sur des réacteurs
nucléaires
oui c'est pas à ces jeux à nouveau de
l'avion il vaut beaucoup mieux qui
s'écrase dans une tour à la défense si
vous voulez faire beaucoup plus de
beaucoup de morts ça sera beaucoup plus
efficace pourquoi pas ce que vous pensez
vous êtes sûr qu'aujourd'hui les
réacteurs elle créait ce que si un avion
s'écrase sur un réacteur nucléaire 1
vous aurez peut-être je dis bien
peut-être une fuite de matériaux
radioactifs qui ne fera pas de millemont
instantané mais alors que si l'avion
s'écrase dans une tour à la défense on a
très bien vu ça à manhattan ça marche
très très bien vous faites quelques
milliers de mort instantanée
donc il fait beaucoup mais c'est
beaucoup moi si je suis terroriste chez
beaucoup plus envie de l'écraser dans
une tour que de m'écraser sur une
centrale nucléaire
jean marc jancovici
on va continuer d'évoquer l'actualité de
l'énergie et cette fois ci on ne parlera
plus de nucléaire je rappelle que vous
êtes président du think tank the shift
project et professeur à mines paristech
qu'on se retrouve donc dans quelques
minutes pour évoquer par exemple le
charbon puisque donald trump s'est
félicité l'un des locales pétrole en
france parce que le charbon n'a pas
beaucoup bon on en parle aux environs de
8 heures 20 en attendant il est 8 heures
et je vous souhaite un excellent réveil
7h 9h les matins de france culture
guillaume erner retour sur le terrain de
l'énergie nous sommes en compagnie de
jean marc jancovici président du film
tant que chief project et professeur à
mines paristech
tout à l'heure vous évoquiez la question
du risque nucléaire pour dire que
celui-ci vous paraissez mesure et qu'il
n'y avait pas véritablement de raisons
pour vous d'être inquiet ce que la
décision de donald trump de remettre en
service le charbon de vanter les mérites
du magnifique charbon propre site
les mots donald trump le magnifique
charbon propre américain est ce que cela
vous inquiète plus jean marc jancovici
alors ce qu'il faut savoir c'est que les
états unis c'est le système le plus
parlementaire au monde
dans les démocraties et que l'exécutif a
très peu de pouvoir
en fait l'essentiel du pouvoir aux états
unis appartient au parlement appartient
aux états fédérés
ce que fait le président on peut avoir
de l'influencé dans quelques domaines
bien précis mais il ya un domaine dans
lequel le président n'a aucun pouvoir
c'est le prix du charbon versus le prix
du gaz or il se trouve que les états
unis c'est un pays alors les états unis
possède les premières réserves de
charbon au monde donc ils ont
potentiellement
la possibilité de mettre beaucoup
beaucoup de dioxyde de carbone dans
l'atmosphère avec ce charbon
par ailleurs il faut savoir que le
charbon est essentiellement une énergie
domestique
vous avez moins de 10% du charbon vapeur
celui qui sert à faire de l'électricité
qui passe une frontière dans le monde
entre pays de production et de
consommation donc c'est une énergie qui
voyagent peu le donc les états unis ont
plein de charbon mais il se trouve que
depuis dix ans la place du charbon dans
la production électrique parce que c'est
essentiellement à ça que ça sert le
charbon est en train de baisser au
profit du gaz parce que avec le gaz de
roche mère qu'on appelle en france le
gaz de schiste qui s'est développée le
prix du gaz est extrêmement bas aux
états unis depuis maintenant une dizaine
d'années et c'est plus rentable de faire
de l'électricité avec du gaz qu avec du
charbon
donc le charbon est en perte de vitesse
aux états unis et les gesticulations de
trump en ce qui concerne le charbon ne
sont là que pour rassurer son électorat
qui vient dans les états charbonniers
metrohm ta strictement aucune espèce
d'influencé sur ce qui se passe en ce
qui concerne le charbon mais alors
est-ce que ça devrait quand même nous
faire peur est ce que le fait d'utiliser
plutôt du charbon du gaz de schiste jean
marc jancovici est ce que ça par exemple
ça représente un risque pour vous alors
ça dépend ce qu'on appelle un risque le
changement climatique est un risque pour
donner un ordre de grandeur
il faut savoir que la différence de
température moyenne qui lie à entre la
dernière ère glaciaire où la france
ressemblait au nord de la sibérie
actuelle et le monde que nous avons
trouvé en entrant j'ai envie de dire
c'est à dire le monde très industrielle
il ya un siècle et demi l'élévation de
température moyenne sur terre n'a été
que de 5 degrés donc avec 5 degrés de
hausse de température moyenne vous
transformez la france qui ressemblait au
nord de la sibérie actuelle en ce
qu'elle est aujourd'hui
l'océan est monté de 120 m avec 5 degrés
de hausse
donc ce qu'il faut comprendre c'est que
le changement climatique a le potentiel
de tuer des milliards de gens je dis
bien des milliards de gens et il a le
potentiel de déclencher la guerre
partout sur terre le giec dans un
rapport qui a été rendu il ya pas très
longtemps qui ce changement climatique
et terre disait qu'à partir de trois
degrés de hausse de la température
moyenne il y aura de l'insécurité
alimentaire généralisée sur terre
et l'insécurité alimentaire déclenché
une insécurité politique partout parce
que vous connaissez le vieux dicton
ventre affamé n'a point d'oreille et il
ya mille exemples mille exemples le
pardon de ce que je viens de dire sur
terre donc le changement climatique a le
potentiel de rendre la vie de vos
enfants je peux si vous en avez
particulièrement infernale
donc tous ceux qui contribuent à la
hausse des émissions de co2 a le
potentiel de contribuer à rendre la vie
des gens particulièrement infernale
alors le fait de consoles de consommer
plus de charbon y contribue donc à
l'évidence à ce potentiel
par contre le fait de remplacer du
charbon par du gaz à consommation
constante insiste sur le fait que c'est
à consommation constante
par contre ça fait baisser les émissions
de co2 donc le grand paradoxe de ce qui
est en train de se passer aux états unis
en ce moment c'est que le forage de gaz
de roche mère que tout le monde
considère être une catastrophe
environnementale sur le strict plan du
co2 c'est plutôt une bonne affaire mais
le problème c'est comme vous venez de le
dire que cela d'autres contreparties
qu'est ce que vous en pensez de ces
contreparties pour le gaz là les autres
contreparties et bien par exemple les
pollutions provoquées par le gaz de
schiste quelle pollution alors
différents types de pollution il y à la
pollution qui est lié à ce que l'on
injecte dans la terre pour les chasses
gaz de schiste c'est pas une pollution
très enquiquinante en l'occurrence qu'on
met dans la terre pour extraire le gaz
de schiste et de l'eau avec quelques
additifs qui sont de l'ordre de l'eau de
javel tombé dans la piscine et de la
haie delà du produit de vaisselle on a
un peu de et des gélifiants qu'on trouve
dans les cosmétiques
on a mini tremblement de terre tout
petit tremblement de terre sur oki par
le gaz de schiste alors dans les
tremblements de terre il ya en un qui
est provoqué par du gaz pas de schiste
qui est beaucoup plus rigolo mais c'est
aussi des mini tremblements de terre les
halls sera pour vous c'est hollande
reste chez quitteront par rapport à ce
que je viens d'évoquer sur le changement
climatique ou c'est totalement
secondaire et par rapport aux 5 millions
de gens qui meurent chaque année des
accidents de voiture c'est totalement
secondaire et par rapport aux gens qui
meurent chaque année du tabac et de
l'alcool c'est totalement secondaire
donc c'est pas qu'elle ne peut pas se
prévaloir quand même des gens qui
meurent du tabac pour valider les gaz de
schiste gens ne peut se prévaloir du
fait que quand on a que 24 heures par
jour et que les moyens budgétaires qu'on
a on choisit ses priorités donc une
manière qu'ont pas à gérer on peut pas
résoudre tous les problèmes en même
temps donc une bonne façon de gérer ses
priorités c'est de se dire si je ne gère
15 e
problème ces locales ensuite si je n'en
gère qu'un deuxième derrière ces lequel
etc et les tremblements de terre le gaz
de schiste a plus d'inconvénients mais
les tremblements de terre provoquées par
le gaz de schiste ça n'est pas quelque
chose qui est j'avais la géothermie qui
est une énergie renouvelable provoque
aussi des tremblements de terre quand on
met des installations continue petit
temple pour extraire du kerala les cours
des norias de camions et de l'oapam
c'est un vrai je suis en train de dire
que les gaz de schiste c'est l'eldorado
je suis juste en train de vous dire
qu'un des effets paradoxaux de
développement du gaz de schiste aux
états unis c'est que ça a contribué à
faire baisser les émissions de co2 du
pays
voilà c'est juste ça que je suis en
train de vous dire si vous deux ans et
les 6 énergétique c'est parti des halles
jean marc jancovici non on va prendre le
problème dans l'autre sens si on veut
rester sous les deux degrés qui sont
aujourd'hui dans toutes les têtes
en ce qui concerne le changement
climatique à l'avenir il faut que les
émissions mondiales de co2 baisse de 4%
par an à partir de demain matin encore
demain matin -4 % par an
ça veut dire que la quantité de pétrole
de gaz et de charbon qu'on utilise
baisse en euros 2 4% par an là dedans
vous avez des arbitrages
si vous remplacez du charbon par du gaz
ça vous permet de gagner un peu de temps
sur le fait que vous conservez autant
d'énergie c'est à dire autant du monde
moderne tout en baissant les émissions
de co2 mais globalement il faut baisser
sa 4% par là dedans ni les énergies
renouvelables ni le nucléaire ne
permettront de compenser cette baisse
pour conserver le confort moderne
donc il faut bien comprendre que de
lutter contre le changement climatique
c'est de se mettre au régime
bon ça c'est une première chose dont on
réussit jour en hausse de 4% et c'est en
grosse mise au régime qui n'épargnera
même pas les gens qu'on appelle modeste
d'accord c'est une grosse mise au régime
donc le non-dit politique majeur
aujourd'hui parce que les économistes
utilisent des modèles totalement
farfelue pour dire que les deux sont
compatibles c'est que ça n'est pas
compatible avec la croissance économique
s'est même pas compatible avec le
maintien de la production économique
actuel
donc ça veut dire perte de pouvoir
d'achat pour être très clair pour tout
le monde pas juste pour lech
pourquoi une perte de pouvoir d'achat
une perte en tout cas une diminution 2
parce que se battre au régime c'est plus
l'impression est ce que ça peut pas
passer par exemple par une meilleure
isolation des maisons par l'ifa est
aussi mais c'est aussi par moins
d'espacé habitable par personne c'est
aussi par moins de moyens mécanisés de
se déplacer par personne c'est aussi par
moins de fringues et d'objets de toutes
natures ht par personne etc
c'est moins de tout ça bon donc une fois
qu'on a pousé cela alors une fois qu'on
a posé cela on comprend que le nucléaire
dont on a beaucoup parlé dans cette
première partie est un parachute
ventrale c'est à dire que si on en
utilise pas et bien la décrue
énergétique est encore plus rapide que
si on en utilise et à ce moment
l'effondrement sociale est encore plus
rapide
voilà donc après on choisis ton camp
camarade je vous dis par exemple que les
olives les risques portés par ce genre
de trucs sont très importants alors
l'éolien et le solaire l'éolien vous
savez les moulins à vent c'est connu
depuis 2000 ans il se trouve que
historiquement ont dépassé des moulins à
vent aux combustibles fossiles
donc si les moulins à vent était une
énergie merveilleux sans inconvénient
pas cher et c'est pourquoi est ce qu'on
s'est enquiquiner à passer des moulins à
vent pétrole
peut-être parce qu'on connaît mieux vaut
maintenant non parce qu'on connaissait
très bien le vent il ya 2000 ans et
parce que tout simplement c'est pas vrai
en fait que le vent est une énergie bien
supérieur au pétrole
tant qu'on a pas de problème avec la
quantité de pétrole extractible et tant
qu'on n'a pas de problème avec le
changement climatique le pétrole c'est
vachement mieux que le vent mais
puisqu'on a un problème avec le pétrole
est ce que on aura ce warrant oui mais à
ce moment là on va revenir en quarts en
arrière entre guillemets parce que le
vent c'est une énergie diffuse
qu'extraire de l'énergie du vent ça
demande des moyens qui sont beaucoup
plus lourds que d'extraire de l'énergie
d'un gisement de pétrole
il faut par exemple 100 fois plus de
métal pour avoir un système énergétique
complet c'est-à-dire là où le train de 8
heures par à 8h et par le train de 8
heures par quand il ya du vent d'accord
pour revoir un système complet et
pilotable il faut 100 fois plus de métal
pour avoir de l'éolien et du solaire que
pour avoir un système qui est basée sur
les centrales électriques classiques que
nous avons aujourd'hui on est bien
d'accord que l'éolien à des problèmes de
souplesse qu'il a reçus il a des
problèmes de consommation de matériaux
c'est à dire que comme l'énergie du vent
et diffuse à la base il faut des très
gros dispositif pour extraire des
grandes quantités d'énergie il
un certain nombre de défauts mais
aujourd'hui on dit que si on appelle ça
des défauts on a des faiblesses visant
des cheveux aller jusqu'au bout que le
prix du kilowattheure fournis par
l'éolien est aujourd'hui au même prix
que le nucléaire si on intègre tous les
coups north nucléaire intégré pas tous
les coups de l'éolien dans cette affaire
parce que vous intégrez tous les coûts
du nucléaire et charleville
démantèlement des centrales joliment oui
le démantèlement ces 10% du coût de
construction
c'est pas très cher le démantèlement
parce que le démantèlement c'est aller
avec des signes étaient coupées vous
êtes sûr c'est si peu cher que sa basse
et je suis tout à fait sur wii
donc c'est à peu près 10% 10 15% si
vraiment vous voulez ceinture et
bretelles et chez pas quoi et que vous
avez peur de trucs qui sont pas
justifiées mais voilà son nez dans ses
enfants de grandeur là il ya des tas de
centrales en dans le monde qui ont été
retournés au gazon donc on a des
matières taux d'il ya des retours
d'expérience vous avez en france d
installation en cours de démantèlement
ce moment il va y avoir une vingtaine à
peu près vous avez toute la filière
rafidia ce qui est en cours de
démantèlement vous avez plein de
réacteur de recherche qui sont en cours
de démantèlement
la petite soeur ou le petit frère de
superphénix qui s'appelle fénix qui a
fonctionné très bien pendant 30 ans à
marcoule est en cours de démantèlement
en fait le plein de trucs qui sont en
cours de démantèlement
ça pose pas de problème majeur se pose
des problèmes en il faut être un peu
précautionneux mais ça pose pas problème
majeur donc l'éolien pour en revenir à
ce que je disais sur le sur l'éolien le
coût du mégawattheure qu'on annonce
comme étant faible est un coup avec
lequel le train de 8 heures par s'il ya
du vent ce qui veut dire que l'éolien ne
peut pas être la seule partie du mix
énergétique il faut dire que l'éolien
pour comparer ce qui est comparable
il faut comparer le coût d'un système
pilotable que ce soit une centrale un
barrage hydroélectrique vous tourner le
robinet vous avez d'électricité
centrales nucléaires vaut tourner le
robinet vous avez d'électricité une
centrale à gaz ou tourner le robinet
vous avez d'électricité l'éolienne vous
tournez pas le robinet vous attendez que
du vent si vous voulez tourner le
robinet pour que l'électricité il faut
rajouter à l'éolienne le dispositif de
stockage qui va derrière pour être sûr
que le train de 8 heures parts à 8h et à
ce moment donc des batteries
non aujourd'hui les systèmes dans le
stockage de l'électricité qui est le
plus fréquemment répandue c'est des
barrages réversible qu'on appelle des
stations de pompage les battre vous un
problème écologique qui posant problème
écologique parce qu'il faut faire les
barrages mais les batteries pose un
problème écologique parce que faire une
batterie c'est de l'industrie métallique
enfin ses lacets de la métallurgie et
donc il faut faire les mines
vous n'avez pas d'énergie sans
contrepartie ça n'existe pas donc il
faut choisir les contreparties par
contre ce qui est sûr c'est qu'avec la
quantité de métal qu'il faudrait pour
avoir des batteries partout pour avoir
des éoliennes partout
vous serez mort et vos enfants aussi qu
on y sera toujours pas donc la question
d'avoir un système complet dans le
domaine électrique avec des éoliennes et
des batteries quand vous regardez le
coût global de cette affaire ce que j'ai
fait ça vous revient globalement dix
fois plus cher qu'un système nucléaire
même un système nucléaire cher parce que
l'éolienne n'est pas un système complet
c'est un système partiel est-ce que vous
avez intégré tous les coûts y compris
les coûts avec des éventualités fait
faible mais réel comme par exemple ce
qui s'est passé à fukushima et qui doit
être intégré dans les cours oui oui
parce que vous région rendue inhabitable
non la région n'est pas rendue
inhabitable fukushima voulez vous alors
là je préférerais g sans hésiter une
seconde
si on me donne le choix entre habiter à
fukushima et habitait à côté d'une usine
chimique ou à côté d'une autoroute ou à
côté d'une centrale à charbon je vais
habiter à fukushima sans hésiter une
seconde
pourquoi parce que vous préférez un
risque faible mais grave par un risque
que ce n'est pas faible mais grave le
risque neigeux l'un je répète ce que
j'ai dit tout à l'heure les rapports de
lune ce qu'est arts vous dit ce qu' il
n'y a pas de risque à cause du surplus
de rayonnement mais s'est excusé moi je
comprends pas ce que ça veut dire parce
que nous mêmes pas d'avis la main aux
copains journalistes ont lieu d'exister
je suis moi-même journalistes shonali
j'ai aussi des amis experts et lesquels
mais qu'il est enfin de retour dans les
rayons explique ben c'est pas des
experts du coup c'est des gens vous
invitais mais pas des experts est alors
par exemple tchernobyl qu'est ce qui va
devenir un médecin fait venir le chef du
service de médecine nucléaire de la
pitié salpêtrière je peux vous donner
ses coordonnées il vous expliquera lui
est un expérience moi je suis là pour
vous écouter de toute façon mais va
devenir un médecin puisqu'il a est passé
pourquoi les radios n'invite jamais de
médecins quand il s'agissait des seuls
qui par deux jours non vous éviter de
vous inviter des associatives vous
inviter des gens comme moi vous invitez
pas de médecins non invité un médecin la
vie des gens h et à rejeter cherche des
gens pour le nuc il n'y a pas de ranchi
contre les experts vous savez alors il
ya des faits et les opinions en ce qui
concerne les faits comme par exemple le
fait que la terre est ronde ya pas de
gens à charge et à décharge
vous n'allez pas invité dans studio
enfin vous pouvez si vous voulez inviter
des gens qui disent que la terre est
plate mais je ne pense pas que ça va
améliorer la compréhension du monde des
gens qui vous écoute
donc un expert dans le domaine de
l'impact des rayonnements ionisants sur
la santé s'appelle un médecin voilà donc
ces gens là qui font inviter vous avez
des gens qui s'occupent de médecine
nucléaire dans ce pays c'est ces gens là
qui font invités à vider la vie tout à
fait le droit de défendre le nucléaire
c'est beau surtout par train de défendre
le nucléaire je suis en train pendant un
an je suis entrain défendre quelque
chose de beaucoup plus profond que ça je
suis en train de défendre ce qui fait la
légitimité d'un expert c'est ça que je
suis en train d'aimer le problème c'est
qu'en fait il faut un âne extérieur mais
savoir ce qu'est un exemple un expert ne
s'autoproclame jamais experts ça
n'existe pas ça un expert est considéré
comme expert quand il a une compétence
reconnue par ses pairs
voilà c'est ça et dans et quand il a
publié dans des journaux scientifiques à
comité de lecture des conclusions ou des
théories ou des démonstrations qui n'ont
pas été invalidé par le même canal c'est
ça un expert mais il devrait y avoir
aussi des experts en effroi pour mesurer
par exemple qu'elle a été l'inquiétude
du monde avec fukushima vous dites qui
nous inquiète est-ce que vous citez
l'inquiétude des américains avec orson
welles qui a fait croire qu'il y avait
un débarquement de martiens des cinq ou
six a été élevé donc c'est pas moi je
crois que c'est toi c'est pas parce
qu'on fait capable de coups un effroi
médiatique fukushima c'était pas un
effroi médiatique recherche est un écran
médiatique vos collègues de france info
ont même osé affirmer que c'était
fukushima qui est fait vingt mille morts
collègues et camarades de france info on
dit mais c'est ça qui est ça y est c'est
fini les gens finissent par le croire il
ya encore trois semaines on expliquait
que fukushima renvoyer des déchets
nucléaires où de l'eau radioactive
pardon clé dans la mer c'est radioactifs
vous savez quelle est la radioactivité
de votre propre corps votre propre corps
c7000 becquerels 3 0 jean marc jancovici
la maladie des rayons elle existe cela
dit des rayons et bien ces gens qui
meurent d'un cancer parce qu'ils ont été
à tchernobyl par exemple pour intervenir
sur le coeur on sur le dow jones qui a
les rapports d'une ce qu'est la rue
disent les conséquences avérées de
tchernobyl ces quelques dizaines de
morts à bref délai qui sont
effectivement les gens qui sont allés
jeter les premiers sacs de sable là sur
le
le réacteur en fusion donc cela il y en
a une bonne partie qui y sont passés
mais ils sont en 50 ans aux îles sont
pas 5000 et ensuite vous avez quelques
milliers de l'ordre de 6000 cas de
cancers à la thyroïde pour des enfants
au moment de l'accident
j'insiste des enfants au moment de
l'accident les adultes au moment de
l'accident il n'y a pas de variation
dans l'incidence des cancers à la
thyroïde parce que votre atyrau ida
arrêté d'accumuler llyod à grande
vitesse et pour le reste le rapport vous
dit il n'y a pas de conséquence
discernable c'est très clairement ce qui
est écrit ce qui doit faire je compte
approximativement déjà environ dix mille
victimes
non si vous comptez les victimes
absolument et danser et dans ces
victimes vous aurez et fait venir encore
une fois un médecin qui va vous en
parlait il faut que l'on a fait venir
tous ces gens mais vous voyez bien quand
même je ne sais pas je suis pas sûr que
vous avez fait venir des médecins pour
cas moi j'en ai pas se battre pour
savoir si on ne prenait jamais en tout
j'en ai jamais entendu à la radio mais
des médecins spécialistes de ce genre de
sujets non non j'en ai jamais entendu on
promet que j'en inviterait j'ai entendu
rivasi et lepage autant que vous voulez
mais alors par contre des médecins
spécialisés à dos mais par contre des
spécialistes dans j'en ai pas entendu
mais ça c'est un mauvais procès à mon
avis parce que le bis nucléaire je suis
très différents partenaires au lobby
nucléaire je suis soit en train de vous
faire un procès je suis juste en train
de constater un fait qui est que si on
fait l'inventaire précis des invités qui
sont passés derrière ce micro et
derrière ceux de vos confrères
il ya quasiment jamais j'ai pas les
chiffres donc là encore une fois on peut
pas débattre et une chose qui ya une
chose qui est certaine c'est que ce qui
s'est passé à fukushima et à tchernobyl
ne peut pas être considérée comme une
péripétie nom s'est passé une chose à
dire vous savez qu'elle est l'accident
d'installations de production électrique
qui a fait le plus de morts dans le
monde
lorsque je vous pose une question vous
répondez par une autre question c'est un
procédé que je connais bien mais ça veut
dire que dans ces pages suis pas en
train de faire a dit jacobs suis en
train de vous poser une vraie question
c'est les barrages qui ont tué le plus
de gens dans le monde de très très loin
de très loin la l'accident qui a eu beau
parent âge l'ont garonne en italie dans
les années cinquante a fait 2500 morts
2500 morts en france il ya un ouvrier
qui se laisse tomber un marteau sur le
pied dans une centrale nucléaire il a
fait les gros titres des journaux
donc on est vraiment je vous assure en
train de se focaliser sur ce sujet là
parce que c'est un sujet passionnel que
sympathique pour faire du buzz
et c'est ça n'est pas éduquer
correctement les gens nous parce que
alors si vous les ja nassim nicholas
taleb qui est un philosophe et c'est
évoquer la notion de cygne noir gris
noir c'est un oiseau hne
parce que bientôt on attendait là on a
un 'cygne noir' énorme s'appelle le
changement climatique on s'en occupe pas
mais non mais vous vous considérez que
le changement climatique on va s'en
occuper avec du nucléaire et du gaz de
schiste je considère que si on ne fait
pas de nucléaire globalement on augmente
le risque
non c'est ça que je suis en train de
vous considérer qu'il n'y a pas d'autres
possibilités pas du tout ce que je vous
ai dit je vous ai dit la première chose
qu'on allait faire voyez vous êtes comme
autres tous vos copains j'ai dit que la
première chose qu'il fallait faire cette
et se mettre au régime
j'ai pas dit que la première chose qui
vous avez dit qu'il fallait se mettre au
régime il ya une preuve et un
enregistrement sonore où ceux du bac il
ya vu justement cinq minutes nous
confesse mémoire congé pas la mémoire
courte parce que je sais que vous avez
expliqué là aussi que pour le gaz de
schiste alors je sais pas si vous avez
le goût du paradoxe mais moins a priori
effectivement j'ai entre pas le goût du
paradoxe verser les 10 que le gaz de
schiste avait une caractéristique
tunisien une caractéristique je dis pas
c'est merveilleux où c'est un vin une
caractéristique c'est qu'il a contribué
à faire baisser les émissions de co2 des
états unis c'est un fait voilà c'est
tout après on peut être pour ou contre
c'est un autre sujet je vous dis juste
il a contribué à cet effet là parce
qu'il a parce qu'il a déplacé du charbon
dans la production électrique
les allemands avec leurs éoliennes ont
gagné beaucoup moins de charbon dans la
production électrique que les américains
car gaz de schiste voilà ça c'est un
fait
après on peut débattre de comment est-ce
qu'on interprète de ce fait quels
enseignements et on en tire quel recul
on prend sur cette situation et c'est
très bien discuter de ce genre de chose
par contre c'est un fait et le
photovoltaïque dont on a peu parlé aux
enfants seront morts que ça aura pas
changer la situation de la planète
bon ben alors dr skala ça veut dire que
effectivement pour vous le pilier de la
transition c'est les économies fait non
c'est la 4 % par an si je vous ai bien
suivi l'économie le pilier de la
transition ça va être de se mettre au
régime
et de toute façon cette mise au régime a
déjà commencé en france que ça vous
plaise ou que ça vous plaise pas parce
que l'europe si on avait parlé de ça au
lieu de parler du nucléaire pendant 40
minutes contrairement à ce que j'avais
envie de faire
l'europe est déjà en décrue énergétique
subi je vais finir ma phrase si vous
permettez
l'europe est en décrue énergétique subit
depuis 2007
et c'est ça qui fait que les
gouvernements même de gauche et même
généreux ne font pas revenir la
croissance en europe parce que c'est
devenu physiquement impossible à cause
de ça donc on va devoir transitionner en
récession
et ça veut dire les décrues énergétique
subi ça veut dire qu'on même si on
voulait consommer plus d'énergie on ne
pourrait pas et que maintenant on en a
de moins en moins de moins en moins de
renouvelables non renouant 4 75 % de
l'approvisionnement européen c'est les
fossiles donc c'est le pétrole dont on
n'a pas parlé pendant cette émission
c'est le charbon dont on a très peu
parlé pendant cette émission c'est le
gaz dont on n'a quasiment pas parlé sauf
pour le gaz de schiste voilà ça c'est 75
% de l'approvisionnement européen et en
france si vous regardez l'énergie qui
rentre dans une machine d'accord
l'énergie qui en ce moment fait
fonctionner les équipements de ce studio
votre frigo les voitures qui sont en
train des gens qui sont en train d'aller
au travail
les avions qui volent et c'est 75% de
cette énergie est issu des combustibles
fossiles en france
vous avouerez que c'était pas inutile de
vous faire parler sur le nucléaire
puisque vos propos sont particulièrement
comment dirais-je rares alors chacun
jugera s'il son fond dit il je ne sais
pas mais en tout cas cette énergie
fossile est en décrue subi le gaz qui
rentre en europe aujourd'hui est en
décrue subies depuis 2005 parce que la
mer du nord qui fournit l'essentiel du
gaz européen a passé son pic de
production en 2005
le charbon est en décrue subi en europe
depuis les années 60
parce que ça fait deux siècles comptable
dans les mines et donc il y en avait de
moins en moins et que les anglais ont
fermé leurs mines les français ont fermé
leurs mines etc
il en reste encore beaucoup en allemagne
mais depuis les années 60 n'ont rien à
voir avec le climat et le pétrole est en
décrue subi en europe depuis 2006 parce
que le pétrole conventionnel c'est à
tout ce qui n'est pas pétrole de schiste
et sables bitumineux a passé son pic de
production dans le monde en 2008 sujet
dans les médias ne parle absolument
jamais et donc on ne pourra pas
retrouver structurellement un
approvisionnement pétrolier croissant
pour les voitures et les chaudières
européenne donc on est déjà en décrue
énergétique subit moins d'énergie ça
veut dire moins de machines moins de
machines ça veut dire moins de
production - de production ça veut dire
le pib qui baisse n'en déplaise ou n'en
plaise à monsieur macron et tous ses
copains
donc ça c'est un sujet important
j'aurais préféré qu'on parle de ça mais
voilà jean marc jancovici je vous
présente mes trois camarades qui
viennent prolonger cette émission
aurélien bélanger hervé gardette et
mathilde serrell bonjour à tous les
trois rôles de quoi allez vous nous
parlez bien je vais me demander s'il
faut je vais vous demander aussi s'il
faut confier l'elysée un ingénieur il
faut restaurer le lien de confiance
après tant d
j'ai une question évidemment non rb ma
chronique vous réagirez mathilde serrell
si vous parlez du pass culture autopsie
d'une fausse bonne idée
et enfin aurélien bélanger éric zemmour
un folklore français